[Musik]
hallo in ihrem heute gibt es einen
richtigen party snack und zwar machen
wir tacos mit hähnchenbrust und selbst
gemachte mode
das ist meiner meinung nach richtige
fingerfood ihr braucht kein messer keine
gabel legt den teller mit den packers
den nachos und der burg kam ohne einfach
in die mitte eures tisches und dann
macht euch einen gemütlichen abend mit
freunden oder mit der familie
für die leckere work am ohne benötigen
wir avocados meine band ziemlich klein
deswegen habe ich die vier stücke
könnten auch drei mittelgroße nehmen
außerdem noch den saft einer halben
zitrone eine grob gewürfelt salz und
pfeffer zu würzen und 2 bis 3
knoblauchzehen
jetzt müssen alle zutaten entweder mit
dem pürierstab püriert werden oder wie
ich es mache hier in dem mixa gibt dafür
einfach die avocado sie zwiebeln salz
und pfeffer und dem zitronensaft hinein
und fertig doch kurz miteinander
[Musik]
ich rate euch trotzdem ein bisschen
abzuschmecken dann könnt ihr noch
schauen ob damit in der seite oder mein
zitronen das mit hinzu muss und wenn ich
dann meine passten artige masse erhalten
habt könnt ihr das ganze erstmal eure
schüssel umfüllen
ein
nun werden da noch die knoblauchzehen
mit hineingepresst das ganze bedingten
umgerührt und dann ist die kommune so
weit fertig
[Musik]
das lasse ich jetzt abgedeckt im
kühlschrank stehen bis ich distanziere
und weiter geht's mit dem salat für den
salat schneide ich mir das gemüse ganz
klein ich nehme am liebsten den meister
bei stada habe ich richtig schöne kleine
und gleichmäßige stücke das müsst ihr
aber wirklich ihr könnt auch einfach ein
messer benutzen dauert doch noch etwas
länger
und jetzt geht's endlich zum leckeren
hähnchen füllung liebe benötigen wir
eineinhalb hähnchenbrustfilets die habe
ich schon in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten weil fein gehackte zwiebeln
2 esslöffel honig 3 knoblauchzehen an
gewürzen brauchen curry paprika flockes
pfeffer und profumo außerdem drei
esslöffel speisestärke passierte tomaten
etwas öl zum ausbacken und ein wenig
sojasauce als erstes werden die
hähnchenbrustfilets zusammen mit den
gewürzen richtig schön vermengt ich
mache das am liebsten mit den händen
tragen dabei gerne handschuhe und wenn
ihr das richtig gut vermischt haft kommt
noch etwas sojasaucen mit hinzu ich habe
ca 3 esslöffel genommen
sobald das ganze auch gut vermischt
wurde gegen den speisestärke mit hinzu
sieht einfach dazu dass die
hähnchenbrustfilet pausen richtig schön
knusprig werden beim anbraten von
fleisch wird jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
wenig klebrig sein da dürft euch aber
nicht wundern das ist ganz normal und
das legt sich auch beim anbraten dann
wieder also ich würde auf keinen fall
auf die speisestärke verzichten auf dem
herd geht's dann weiter hier lasse ich
das öl erst mal erhitzen und gäbe dann
die zwiebel mit hinzu nach circa zwei
minuten gebe ich dann auch noch die
clorox ihn mit dazu lasse das ganze
schön dünsten und anschließend kommt das
fleisch mit rein
das fleisch wird dann von allen seiten
richtig gut angebraten und dann lass dir
das ganze so lange in der pfanne bis es
durch ist und rührt dabei immer wieder
um am besten macht ihr das dann auf
mittlerer stufe damit euch das ganze
nicht anbrennt und wenn das fleisch dann
gas geben wir den bonus mit hinzu
[Musik]
anschließend noch die passierten tomaten
mit einarbeiten und damit die kühlung
auch schon fertig
zum befüllen der tacos deutsche jetzt
alles parat liegen also einmal doch
gleich der vorbereitete salat dann habe
ich die kleine tortilla brote
salatblätter und ein paar fein gehackte
frühlingszwiebeln
die tortillas werden jetzt ohne fett auf
mittlerer stufe in der pfanne erhitzt
und zwar pro seite 2 minuten
anschließend geben wir darauf bei
salatblätter darauf kommt dann der salat
die flüssigkeit wir dann nämlich von den
salatblättern aufgefangen und auch für
mich ganz gut darüber geben wir dann
reichlich von dem gleich wer mag kann da
noch von der kamera drauf geben ich
wollte dass abgelassen damit dass ihr
selber entscheiden kann und ganz oben
drauf kommen dann noch bei mir
frühlingszwiebeln
[Musik]
zum anrichten habe ich dann die tacos
ein bisschen fixiert und zwar mit einem
halben veranschlagt und dann gebe ich
einfach auf einen hübschen teller
guacamole kommt in die mitte und was das
jetzt nicht fehlen natürlich die nachos
und so wird das ganze dann sinniert und
ich finde das einfach richtig einladend
aus man hat richtig lustig aus man
direkten natur zu greifen liga kam ohne
tücken denn anschließend aktion ist
einfach super cool wenn man einfach
zusammen sitzt und sich einen schönen
abend macht
natürlich könnt ihr auch stadt der
barcarole jeden anderen weg nehmen ob
das jetzt ihre soße ist oder einfach mit
ketchup und mayo ich gebe euch nur die
anregung aber die tacos empfehle ich
euch definitiv nach zu machen denn wir
haben unglaublich lecker geschmeckt
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr dem video
einen daumen nach oben gibt und mir ein
abo dallas damit ihr auch nichts mehr
von mir verpasst bis zum nächsten mal
objektiv kitchen